Manuel Padilla is chief of the Rio
Grande Valley sector of Customs and
Border Protection he is responsible for
the busiest area of illegal crossings in
the country and for implementing the
policy he's with us now for an interview
that you'll see only on CBS this morning
chief Padilla we thank you very much for
joining us because I know you were
hearing the conversation and hearing a
lot of the heated conversation people
say that the zero tolerance policy
actually means zero humanity what do you
say to that yes thank you Miss Gayle
thank you for being here at the busiest
location on the border 40% of all the
apprehensions happen in this sector
forty-four percent of all the seizures
of marijuana happen in the sector and
when we compared to the rest of the the
southwest border so with that those are
just numbers it's a very complex
situation when you have high levels of
activity and a lack of resources
personnel technology and infrastructure
it creates kind of this chaotic
environment this chaotic environment
manifests itself by vehicle rollovers we
had a terrible case yesterday where I've
lost their lives yeah we have over a
thousand rescues where the agents are
rescuing people on a daily basis and
then we also have the stash houses where
people are just subjected to just
terrible conditions while they're being
held as they're being smuggled this
muddling really fuels the cartel
violence on the south side and so we're
talking about zero zero tolerance policy
we have done different efforts
throughout the years 2014 we started
detaining this population of family
units because I don't want to go back to
2014
I know that this is complicated for you
and your team but what people are
talking about is cruel and humane
behavior is how it's perceived do you
actually agree with this policy are you
carrying out well I tell you I do agree
that we have to do something we created
the situation by not doing anything so
what happens with zero tolerance is we
were exempting a group and population
from the law and what happens when you
do that it creates a vacuum it creates a
draw for a certain group of people to
that rises to trans that are that
I'm a crisis I'm gonna give you an
example here because we were releasing
family units we were not taking any
action May 2nd just last month we had an
ms-13 full-blown ms-13 accompanied by
his one-year-old child mm-hmm he thought
he was going to get released into the
community that was not the case but help
us understand how we are seeing the
pictures and hearing the stories of
mothers and children who are their
children I met a woman yesterday where
they were separated for six days who
would who was fleeing because she was
afraid of gang violence help us
understand why some of the families are
being told that your children are going
to be taken - given a bath and then they
don't see their children how is that
okay so very respectfully miss Gail
that's misinformation that is up there
there's a story about removing a child
from a breastfeeding mother absolutely
not true every family member gets a
sheet with information to keep track of
their child to get information where
that child all reunited at the where I
was yesterday I had parent after parent
tell me they weren't told where their
child was going that their child was
just being taken away that they had no
way to communicate with their children
that's not misinformation that's someone
that I heard with my own ears and was
talking to the people that is
misinformation then very respectfully so
let me give you another piece of
misinformation if they're saying it to
me or they are telling the truth to me
well no we have a sheet that we give and
we came out with a sheet that we give to
the parents because that was a potential
gap of information parents just being
you know apart from their from their
children need information what is going
to happen so there's a information sheet
that explains the entire process you
violated the law you are going to go
through the judicial process while
you're going through this process you
are going to be separated from your
child temporarily separated from your
child and then reunited at the at the
point when you serve your sentence let
me give another piece of our does it
seem like a cruel and inhumane treatment
to you
ma'am we do
with the united states citizens of a
united states citizens violates the law
and that person is accompanied by his or
her children and they're going through a
judicial process the children are
separated from that parent because the
kids are not going through that process
so I think a lot of people lose sight
the other thing that people use that
we're all too emotional about this I
think that's a very good point if we
look at this situation without emotion
and without politics to be to be honest
with the allman operator men your father
and I am a father and if we look at this
objectively we have to do something
because when you have this flow of
people and these people are fleeing
poverty and fleeing other things and
viley understood but when you have this
flow of people that Trek is so dangerous
over a thousand rescues this year that's
like you're wrapping me up I have to go
but I have to say with all due respect I
think it's hard to look at this story
without emotion but I really appreciate
you taking the time to talk thank you
for coming down here and understanding
thank you we're very glad to be here we
will have more from South Texas in our
next half-hour but right now let's send
it back to John and Nora and Alex in New
York okay Gail thanks so much very
complicated situation here I think what
the chief didn't exactly explain is the
change in zero-tolerance policy that's
led to these increases which is treating
these parents that come in as criminals
when once you start doing that then you
have to separate the children from them
and that's what creates the new
conditions in addition to all the old
conditions right we'll have a lot more
on this yeah we're gonna explain that
decision and the policy change coming up